so I write again as a similar
relationship in biology the question is
one of the parts and what's the whole I
may have a bunch of molecules if I do a
synchronic story and I say I've got you
know I've got demon globin molecules and
and you know all the molecules that make
me up
am I just this collection of these
molecules well in fact the molecules are
each made by each other they don't exist
independently they wouldn't exist in the
world if there wasn't this complex in
one sense to describe the parts you
already need to know something about the
whole you need is something about its
history there's there's not a nice nice
neat compositional story of you told
here it's a compositional story across
time in which the reason that I have
hemoglobin and that that hemoglobin is
such a hugely you know highly probable
molecule on the surface of the earth has
this incredible history which is always
involved in animal bodies in oxygen in
that sense you can't decompose the body
and say okay all these molecules this
explains the body the molecules each
explain each other in a troublesome sort
of fused way and since it's it's an
analogous kind of fusion in which you
can't do this sort of Miria logical
reconstruction - you you are a mystery
mongering what is probably the clearest
case of reductionism in all of molecular
and in addition the diachronic history
from the beginning of formation of the
earth until the point at which oxygen
begins to not be a toxin that begins to
be an agent of life right is also
something that is entirely explicable
from I'm not I want to be clear that I'm
not saying it's not to confirm or
disconfirm what I've said so I want to
be clear that there's nothing that I've
said or suspect here that has anything
that is not based upon fundamental laws
of physics that's not what I'm claiming
okay fine claiming is that the specific
molecules that make you and I up are the
result of a series of accidental
features in which they have constrained
each other one after the other and the
only accents like in seeing this whole
scenario or a quantum mechanic
indeterminacies if the side from notice
the whole thing is predictable so
besides the fact that the whole base of
it is in determines well except the I
mean insofar as n-terminus the effects
of course of biological evolution we
don't know that I mean I think it does
because mutations are probably farm
phenomena but but it's still bit but
still at the bottom of the laws of
physics
funny thing about this yeah I agree
we're very creaky I have this is not
about magic this is about trying to
figure out how best to describe these
phenomena and what I'm trying to suggest
here is this notion that we're getting
at I think has relevance not just
epistemological but I think it has
relevance but not in actually the
ontology of the emergent process and
that is that things information gets
lost as you move up or as Anderson would
have said that in a sense you can't get
back to it you can't figure out the
details the details don't matter
information gets lost but structure also
recruit right and its traits accrue yeah
so there are principles they're doing
for laws right so yes Sean mentioned a
very short set of what we believe to be
the fundamental laws but there are lots
of principles that those laws obey and
those principles seem to apply at many
different levels if I can stretch it
right now try to think it out as I'm as
I'm talking so for instance conservation
of energy you know you talk about laws
of economics and and those must respect
this principle conservation of energy
right and and that is not a fundamental
law it's simply a principle that's
respected by the fundamental laws and is
able to carry on after we coarse-grain
and lose some information we somehow
retain things like that a principle of
least action things tend to fall along
the path of least resistance it seems to
be universally true again it's not a new
fundamental law that I add to matter and
gravity but matter and gravity respect
this I think the problem is sometimes
you do lose the principles needed here
the system is open and then Energy's not
open service member slow very sure ok
but it's part of how you are defining
your system etc so as long as ok so it
set some boundaries you know you define
your system at such and such a way your
law of economics might not you know
you'd be uniquely because I guess I
didn't fully appreciate why uniqueness
was being invoked earlier be drivable
from from quantum you know field theory
versus some other field theory or some
other sorry theory but it must respect
this principle and that is deeply tied
into the foundational do that is that
interesting or relevant at all
presidents totally are you all gonna
just like talking about these
conversations do you turn into sorry you
oh I just mean this this reductionist
idea it isn't so much that there is some
unique outcome of the coarse graining
process or even that every you know
theory of economics has to have as its
foundation only one unique set of
fundamental laws I mean this uniqueness
seems to me to be not necessary to
invoke but what is necessary is that
there are some principles that survive
the coarse graining even when
information is lost fundamental physics
constrains everything really clear I
don't think anybody here is arguing for
magic or for mysticism for that I said
you can escape fundamental physics right
yeah that's right fun well physics works
the question is how to read how to think
about these problems of transition and
we've been calling levels and yet take
into account the fundamental changes of
causality at the gross gross level at
the the coarse-grain levels you would
call it that that we see the fact that
living processes look like they're doing
things very different than nonliving
processes that mental processes look
like they're doing something very
different from just physiological
processes we want to explain those and
there's some fundamental shifts whether
you call it phase shifts or whatever we
want to have an explanation for that
that does not say I don't investigate
this because there's nothing interesting
there it's all just basic physics of
course it's more than basic physics
there are principles you want a
conference tools I would call them
changes in boundary conditions or
constraints those are what are
interesting and that's what I want to
focus on not the fundamental physics or
if the fundamental physics is somehow
changed you know as we move up the
ladder it's not I mean you use the
example of hemoglobin could you give us
an alternative explanation for the
evolution anything including
nobody give you all whenever organisms
have evolved to the point where as you
say oxygen is no longer a toxin oxygen
killed off most of life
you know it first appeared but there are
lots of ways we can actually get oxygen
and move it around in fact even on earth
there are two kinds of globins to do
this society blow up in an email open
they are big farm constraints so there's
many ways in which provinces cannot
evolve that's right but but there's more
than one way in which you can well this
is a multi multiple realizability
questions it is it's the very variation
of the functionalism story it says okay
how do we account for them what kinds of
what are the rules that we will use in
this game to account for this that don't
violate fundamental physics but help us
explain how these things converge and
why they cross certain thresholds when
they do see the epistemological point
Laplace is demon and a biologist who is
in the process demon are both looking at
some planetary histories and the
biologist says one of two things is
going to happen either this either
you're gonna get hemoglobin we're gonna
get cyan and glow and that depends on
factors that I can't say and Laplace is
Dima is gonna say how do you know this
just two and that fact is a principle
that you get from the higher level
because they're both consistent with
with the underlying physics but biology
tells you that I'm sort of making this
up but that there's there's the two ways
that can go and you don't know which way
it's going to go but you know it's going
to be one way or the other
well the virus that one said is two ways
to go there's two
it hasn't come yeah right right it'll
probably be a medal that plays the role
copper or I mean I just don't understand
what's new here as an evolutionist you
really can't predict what's going to
happen because it's contingent on
mutation rate of mutations that are
essentially unpredictable in the way for
you and environments which are very
difficult to predict so we don't know
what's going to happen but it's it's
also complicated because the mutation
that produces a change in the organism
that changes the environment
it changes the selection order so you
get this incredible non-linearity in
evolutionary biology the remarkable
thing is despite that non-linearity
there's lots of convergence and that
tells if there's lots of constraints out
there that would be nice to know what
those are
you